[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben ihr tiramisu verrückten
meine tiramisu rezept das ist jetzt
übrigens drei jahre her
das ist so oft nach gemacht worden
wirklich so oft und das rezept ist ja
auch nach wie vor gut aber wie bei jedem
rechts israel süßspeise gibt es
verschiedene zubereitungsarten und auch
verschiedene varianten und ich habe eine
neue variante rausgefunden mehr oder
weniger weil ich hatte ricotta im
kühlschrank und hab dann eine creme
gemacht für tiramisu die mir so
unglaublich gut geschmeckt hat und ich
möchte euch das rezept jetzt unbedingt
zeigen und dafür klassische tiramisu
grün wie jetzt zuallererst ein leckeren
kaffee
[Musik]
auf instagram habt ihr ist ja schon
mitbekommen auf youtube jetzt er noch
nicht so es gibt jetzt mein café glück
das sind meine eigenen kaffeebohnen nach
der mischung wie ich sie mag nachdem
rüst grad wie ich es mag und das ganze
wird regional bei uns um die ecke sich
kann vom balkon aus dorthin gucken dort
wird das gerüstet und die bohnen kommen
aus brasilien
ich werde euch das ganze mal in die
infobox verlegen dann könnt ihr euch
gerne da nochmal durchlesen was ich euch
dazu geschrieben habe wir machen jetzt
gerne weiter wie gesagt habe ich hier
eine mischung aus ricotta und ich dem
natürlich mascarpone trennen als capone
oder tiramisu muss meiner meinung nach
recht immer sein um was capone ist sehr
fetthaltig und ricotta ist schon fast
das gegenteil ricotta kann man auch
nicht mit mascarpone oder mit quark
vergleichen das müsste einfach mal
ausprobieren findet ihr auch in jedem
gut sortierten supermarkt also kaufland
hat ist glaube ich auch sogar dauerhaft
im sortiment habe es zumindest immer
dort gefunden und jetzt fahre ich
einfach mascarpone reporter zucker und
vanille extrakt miteinander
[Musik]
anschließend rückt ihr nach und nach
etwas sahne unter und nur ganz kurz
miteinander verrühren und dann ist die
creme auch schon fertig ich verlinke
euch natürlich wie immer alle ganz
genauen mengenangaben hier unten in die
video beschreibung und es geht jetzt
weiter der kaffee ist schön abgekühlt
und dann nehmen wir uns jetzt unseren
löffelbiskuits ganz wichtig tut sie nur
zwei sekunden ein alles andere ist zu
viel und sie werden matschig also 12
rausnehmen ein bisschen abtropfen lassen
und dann in die auflaufform geben
[Musik]
geht das hartgeld tetris gespielt als
nächstes die hälfte der creme drauf
verstreichen muss noch mal ganz kurz
überprüfen ob sie auch wirklich lecker
schmeckt heute unbedingt ausprobieren
das ist ein mega mega lecker so die
hälfte drauf verstreichen und dann
nochmal die zweite schicht
löffelbiskuits dazu geben
[Musik]
die creme habe ich jetzt auch ein
bisschen unregelmäßig verstrichen das
soll so luftig aussehen also ja so finde
ich echt gut also perfekt wir machen da
jetzt cacau drüber und da habe ich einen
kleinen trick ihr könnt euch
hülsenfrüchten zum beispiel rote linsen
weil sonst kommt zu viel durch das sieb
und dann habt ihr so eine richtig dicke
kalkschicht und also ich persönlich mag
das nicht so daher einfach diversen
früchte in der sie ein bisschen cacau ok
also ein bisschen cacau dann sieht man
auch kommt dann nur noch ein bisschen
[Musik]
interessant
und eigentlich ist es schon fertig jetzt
kommt es nur noch für zwei stündchen in
den kühlschrank
nach dem kühlen ist das tiramisu dann im
kühlschrank also müsste es im
kühlschrank lagern ist es dann drei tage
haltbar wenn nicht sogar vier
ich glaube nicht dass sie so lange hält
weil es schmeckt einfach total gut also
diese kombination aus ricotta und
mascarpone müsst ihr unbedingt mal
ausprobieren und schreibt mir dann gerne
in die kommentare ob euch meine andere
variante da hatte ich nämlich doppel ram
frischkäse und auf geschlagene sahne mit
drin ob die euch besser gefällt oder
diese hier weil ich glaube wir haben
eine halbe million aufrufe für das alte
video also da habt ihr auch fleißig
nachgemacht also eigentlich hast du
recht ricotta ist relativ fettarm aber
wir haben trotzdem aus capone drin aber
weniger genau die vorherige version
definitiv und cool finde ich auch dass
man die sahne nichtaufstieg sondern nur
die sahne mit dazu hebt damit die
konsistenz ein bisschen cremiger wird ja
unheimlich maschine dafür also ihr könnt
es auf jeden fall alle nachmachen ganze
freude beim nachmachen und ja abonniert
main kanal kostenlos wenn ihr es jetzt
noch nicht getan habt und dann sehen wir
uns auch beim nächsten video cherokee
okay okay
[Musik]